alors les variants ça dépend desquels je
pense que c'est un peu comme pour tous
chaque fois c'est le rap on a un peu
peur de l'inconnu donc on sait pas
encore s'il pense que ça implique en
plus il ya de nouveaux symptômes ou
autres oui on peut avoir peur après le
var et en anglais par exemple qui était
le premier
ben moi je les ai eus les enfants
n'étaient pas très fort donc au final au
final ça va et ce avec du coup
maintenant que moi je les ai vus j'ai
quand même des anticorps donc voilà je
me permets peut-être à vous plus d'écart
qu'avant mais dans les lieux publics
fait toujours toujours attention voilà
c'est plus en cercle fermé avec des gens
de confiance trop lâche un peu alors non
je vais pas relâcher la vigilance est
bien évidemment et surtout
les vaccins vont être ouverts à tout le
monde bientôt donc moi ça me rassure et
je vais surtout attendre de me faire
vacciner pour ressortir vraiment moi
j'aime pas trop faire la bise surtout
des filles et à le confinement n'est
fait on reprendra ce genre d'habitude et
on fera moins attention à côté de qui on
s'assoit et c'est un peu plus libéré
mais clairement je l'attends vaccins
pour faire ça sinon on fait attention se
met à trois maximum 4 en garde par
rapport aux autres ont gardé distance
non ça me crews préoccupe pas tant que
ça mais je pense que c'est parce que
c'est loin et du coup c'est un peu
difficile de s'en rendre compte et j'ai
un peu relâché ma vigilance were mais je
me suis fait vacciner donc ça devrait le
faire est-ce que son variant inquiète
non je pense pas que l'inquiétude soit
soit pertinent en fait je pense que
voilà il faut être intelligent il faut
faire attention mais s'inquiétait je
pense que ça va ça suffit oui évidemment
on fait attention c'est vraiment un
grand soulagement un grand bonheur de
pouvoir retrouver
nos restaurants et nos bars et voilà il
faut qu'on garde il faut qu'on garde ce
cap là et j'ai pas envie que ça s'arrête
comme tous les autres en fait mais de
manière la grippe aussi elle mute donc
jeu
on verra bien quoi concert confiance je
suis vacciné puis une heure j'ai pas eu
copie
[Musique]
tout va bien donc je pense qu'on va ça
va aller mieux mais avec l'été et c'est
toujours être vaccinés je pense que
c'est bon je me sens pas directement
concerné puisque c'est pas ma zone
géographique du coup et le fait qu'il
ait débloqué des deux mains sur sa
libération parce que du coup je pense
qu'ils vont juguler le variant ça il va
pas s'étendre en france
donc non j'ai pas plus peur que ça
surtout que les variants part ils n'ont
pas été très fin horrible j'ai trouvé et
oui par contre effectivement j'ai
vachement relais de relâcher ma ma
vigilance parce qu'avec les bars on
enlève tout de suite le masque on est
dans une ambiance festive et on n'a plus
envie d'y penser en fait donc oui je
relâcher la vigilance